Scott Landon doesn’t talk a lot
about his childhood to anybody
and at the same time all his books
and stories draw from that childhood.
He grew up in the home of
a dangerous, abusive parent.
Scott Landon had a very,
very painful, troubled past
and had to go to Boo’ya Moon to heal.
It’s this sort of unbelievable, epic place.
It’s almost like a physical
landscape of the subconscious.
And it’s a place that I use to go and
both draw inspiration and heal myself.
When you play a Scott Landon,
when you play a writer that
is somehow like Stephen King,
you have to carry on that internal
world that a writer has.
Because you always wonder, how is it
when they spend hours and hours
just by themselves in front
of a computer just creating.
They become so internal, so
private and I think Clive has that.
Clive is a brilliant, brilliant actor.
You can totally feel and believe that
he has the internal world of a writer.
Mister Dooley, it’s Lisey Landon.
You win, I’ll give you
whatever you want.
Meet me here at 10pm.
I won’t call the police, but
please just don’t hurt me.
Don’t hurt me anymore.
That was good.
No, none of this is good.